why do international exchange rates
interest rates and other economic
indicators fluctuate can they be
controlled can we even make sense of why
these fluctuations in our nation's and
the world's economies occur in this
lecture you'll learn the crucial role of
the central banks and of the
International Monetary Fund in
responding to financial crises around
the world avoiding negative
repercussions in the world's economy and
maintaining and restoring confidence in
the global financial system monetary
policy coordination is delivered by dr.
Michael K Salemi professor of economics
at the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill
professor Salemi has received numerous
teaching awards from UNC Chapel Hill as
well as being recognized nationally with
the bower medal and economic education
from the Council for economic education
and the Villard Award for research and
economic education from the National
Association of economic educators also
in 2007 the Guus a Stavros Center named
him a great teacher in economics on
October 14th 2008 the New York Times
reported what was then some rare good
economic news for the first time that
month the Dow Jones Industrial Average
had actually closed higher than it had
opened indeed as the headline trumpeted
the index had increased by 11 percent
that day what was the source of the good
news well of course it's hard to know
for sure
but Michael Grimm Baum of The Times
attributed it to a coordinated campaign
on the part of governments and central
banks throughout the world to unlock the
global flow of credit in simple terms
governments and central banks work
together
to try to get banks lending again this
lecture is about monetary policy
coordination we will learn what
coordination means and why it is
important and we'll consider two types
of coordination first I will explain the
type of coordination where central banks
of several countries agreed to
simultaneously change interest rates in
the same direction this is the type of
coordination that occurred in October of
2008 which according to the New York
Times was the source of large gains in
stock prices but I will also explain
another type of coordination the type of
coordination implicit in the creation
and operation of the International
Monetary Fund the IMF now you know that
the IMF is often criticized but today
I'd like to suggest that the IMF is
often misunderstood we'll see when and
why the IMF was created will study the
function of the IMF and will consider
why it is appropriate to think of I M F
crisis interventions as a kind of
cooperation among economies and central
banks why is it important to think about
cooperation among central bank's no
economy including the United States is
large enough or important enough or
respected enough to go it alone in a
world where funds move at the speed of
light
across international borders cooperation
is not the policy equivalent of good
manners it's essential no matter how
sensible and important monetary policy
coordination is however it does not
always occur in some cases central
bankers disagree about the relative
importance of monetary policy objectives
and they do go at their own way I will
return to that very point at the end of
the lecture when central bank's
coordinate their monetary policies they
produce superior outcomes to the
outcomes that could be achieved if those
central banks worked in isolation the
news stories in October of 2008 pointed
to a decision by the Federal Reserve and
the central banks of Canada England
Sweden Switzerland in the euro area to
simultaneously announce reductions in
interest rates as it became clear that a
serious recession had begun by
coordinating their actions the central
banks were attempting to avoid changes
in international exchange rates suppose
the Federal Reserve had unilaterally
lowered short-term interest rates in
that case short maturity interest rates
would have become lower in the United
States than in Europe what would have
happened
well bank deposits would then have left
the United States seeking higher rates
in other countries the demand and supply
model that we considered earlier
would represent this this change as an
increase in the supply of dollars - for
example the dollar euro market and that
model would predict a decrease in the
euro price of the dollar put another way
the dollar would depreciate so what well
suppose on the other hand that central
bank's cooperated and lowered interest
rates at the same time and by similar
amounts well in that case bank deposits
do not leave the United States or for
that matter any other country in search
of higher interest rates because there
are no higher interest rates to be found
therefore there is no increase in the
supply of dollars in the dollar euro
market and no depreciation in the dollar
data show that the dollar did not
depreciate in October 2008 as the Fed
lowered interest rates and switched from
a stance where inflation was inflation
was a greater concern to a stance where
recession was the greater concern in
fact in late October the euro price of
the dollar rose from about three
quarters to about eight tenths of a euro
for a dollar
why did central banks want to keep the
dollar from depreciating central banks
and commercial banks and financial
institutions in the respective countries
hold large dollar deposits and a
decrease in the value of the dollar
would have weakened their balance sheets
made their assets worth less a fallen
the value of the dollar
would have made us exports cheaper and
would have started a competitive game
among the nations where each nation
tried to soften the effect of the coming
recession by raising exports at the
expense of other nations but by
coordinating their actions the central
banks were attempting to assure
financial markets that they understood
the severity of the financial crisis and
stood ready as a group to provide
liquidity to financial institutions
throughout the world a coordinated
effort by central banks is more likely
to maintain and restore confidence in
the global financial system then would
be uncoordinated efforts in situations
where inflation is high policy
coordination is absolutely essential to
reducing inflation at the lowest
possible cost of forgone economic
activity the world faced a situation of
high inflation in about 1980 inflation
rates were not simply high in the United
States they were high throughout the
developed world and we know that the
Federal Reserve under the chairmanship
of Paul Volcker took the initiative of
implementing very restrictive monetary
policy the result was a decline in u.s.
inflation over the coming years but as
many believe at the cost of a very
serious recession economists Paul
Krugman and Maurice ops felt have argued
that inflation could have been reduced
throughout the world at the cost of a
milder recession that is at the lower
cost
if central banks had coordinated their
policies at the time Krugman and
Obstfeld liken the policy problem to
what economists call a prisoner's
dilemma game in this game we're going to
suppose two players and home and foreign
our country and some other foreign
country we're gonna assume that they
have similar tastes both countries hate
unemployment and both countries hate
inflation but both countries are
experiencing high enough inflation that
they would be willing to suffer some
increase in unemployment in order to get
their inflation rates down but and this
is crucial both nations would like to
experience the smallest gain in
unemployment that would be possible so
both home and foreign nations are going
to choose one of two policies now there
are infinite number of possible policies
but I'm only going to consider two here
to make the point very clear they can
choose a somewhat restrictive policy or
they could choose a highly restrictive
policy the somewhat restrictive policy
would mean a smaller increase in
interest rates the very restrictive
policy would mean a larger increase in
interest rates so now let's compare
cooperation and non cooperation between
these two countries in the non
cooperative that is no policy
coordination game both home and foreign
will choose the highly restrictive
policy
let's see why suppose home has to move
first that is initiate its policy first
and it has to choose either the somewhat
restrictive or the very restrictive
policy imagine first that home chooses
the somewhat restrictive policy and
lower and raises its interest rates
slightly well then foreign the foreign
country will in response choose the
highly restrictive policy because it
will then be better off at the expense
of the home country why because the
foreign country will have an
appreciating currency and the home
country will have a depreciating
currency the appreciation of the foreign
country's currency will further lower
inflation there while the depreciation
of the home country currency will raise
inflation at home relative to what it
would have been but notice if instead
the home country which had to move first
which had to choose a policy first would
have chosen the more restrictive policy
and raised interest rates led by a lot
well it's true that the foreign country
could not transfer some of its inflation
to the home country because it could not
appreciate its currency relative to home
but nevertheless the right thing for the
foreign country to do is to pick the
highly restrictive policy and there was
nothing about my argument that was
unique to home moving first so we would
see the analysis was exactly the same
symmetric if the foreign country had
moved first conclusion when they do not
cooperate
when they do not coordinate both home
and foreign countries choose the highly
restrictive policy but imagine now a
cooperative game where home and foreign
countries coordinate their monetary
policies and both find it optimal to
choose the somewhat restrictive policy
will that work well keep in mind
inflation is lowered in both countries
but the recession in each country is
milder than it would have been keep in
mind that because they have coordinated
the exchange rate between the two
countries does not change so here
coordination of policy produces a
clearly better remedy a better way to
lower inflation than any remedies that
individual nations could obtain by going
it alone the key to coordination is to
simultaneously implement policy in order
to avoid changes in exchange rates
talking about coordination leads us now
to talk about the International Monetary
Fund why well the International Monetary
Fund often referred to as IMF is an
institution that provides for a
coordinated approach to financial crises
especially financial crises that involve
rapid depreciation of exchange rates now
as we've often seen the IMF is often the
target of angry protests a case in point
were protests in Greece to the austerity
measures adopted by the Greek government
and required by the IMF
as part of an agreement to bail Greece
out from its debt crisis in 2011 where
did the IMF come from what's its origin
well the International Monetary Fund was
created as part of the Bretton Woods
system that reestablished fixed exchange
rates after World War two
the original job of the IMF was to
assist nations that experienced balance
of payments crises which occurred when
financial market participants believed
that a country's currency was overvalued
at the agreed upon pegged to the dollar
but after the world went to flexible
exchange rates floating exchange rates
in 1971 to 72 when the u.s. no longer
pegged the price of the dollar in terms
of gold
the IMF evolved the IMF devolved to
become an international lender to
nations that were experiencing financial
crises that could have dramatically
lowered the exchange value of their
currencies in recent years the IMF has
assisted Mexico in 1994 to 95 several
nations in East Asia in 1997 to 1998
during the so-called Asian financial
crisis and as we've already seen both
Greece and Ireland during the subprime
financial crisis that began in 2008
the IMF website explains that the IMF's
job and its work entails three kinds of
tasks first oversight of world financial
the world financial
system and the financial and economic
policies of its members now as part of
this job
the IMF collects and publishes data on
the world's economies second provision
of technical assistance to countries to
help them manage their economies and
third and most important international
lending the IMF website explains this
last job in the following way and I
quote the IMF provides loans to
countries that have trouble meeting
their international payments and cannot
otherwise find sufficient financing on
affordable terms this financial
assistance is designed to help countries
restore macroeconomic stability by
rebuilding their international reserves
stabilizing their currencies and paying
for Emperor imports all necessary
conditions for relaunching growth the
IMF also provides concessional loans to
low-income countries to help them
develop their economies and reduce
poverty
end quote the IMF faces the same very
difficult trade-off in fulfilling its
role as an international lender that the
Federal Reserve and any central bank
faces in fulfilling its role as
guarantor of the financial system and
regulate or of that same system on one
in loans from the IMF can save a
nation's financial system when it's
under stress during a financial crisis
suppose for example there's a financial
crisis in let's say Korea suppose the
crisis began
with the recession that is quickly
followed by a decrease in private
lending to Korean banks and to Korean
firms suppose that the crisis gains
international attention when several
Korean banks fail because they are
unable to raise new funds sufficient to
pay short-term debts that the banks have
incurred in order to fund investment
projects as the crisis develops deposits
will flee Korea in search of safe havens
and safe harbors depositors in Korea
will remove funds from the crisis nation
and move them to firms in stable
economies often the United States the
shift in deposits from Korea to the US
will clearly lead to depreciation of the
Korean Won that's the name of the Korean
currency Korean depositors will increase
the supply of lon to the wan dollar
market and the dollar price of the wan
will fall the fall in the wand deepens
the crisis for several reasons many
Korean debts will be denominated in
dollars and those debts will become a
bigger burden to Korea as the value of
the Hwan Falls bank balance sheets in
Korea will deteriorate as the
probability for default increases the
wand price of oil will increase placing
further pressure on the Korean economy
alone from the IMF can make it possible
for banks and other financial firms in
Korea to pay their debts with banking
with backing from the IMF
depositors will have less reason to
remove their funds and exchange rate
stability will be restored the wand will
probably not return to its pre-crisis
level but the dollar price of the one
will stop falling on the other hand
loans from the IMF in a financial crisis
can cause moral hazard problems if banks
and other lenders in Korea understand
that the IMF will step in during a
crisis and rescue them they have less
incentive to engage in prudent lending
practices
if the Korean central bank understands
that the IMF will step in during a
crisis and provide dollar loans to
stabilize the wan and the Korean economy
it has less incentive to oversee its
banks in a diligent way to mitigate the
moral hazard problems while still
assisting in a financial crisis the IMF
makes adoption of austerity measures a
requirement for emergency lending
austerity measures are not popular the
austerity measures for Greece were
designed to force Greece to balance it
it's government budget and they included
higher taxes lower government spending
including lower spending for social
programs and mandatory interest payments
on IMF loans the austerity measures are
often very unpopular
and our the most immediate source of
political unrest the IMF plays an
essential role in maintaining worldwide
financial stability without the IMF
small financial crises could frequently
turn into big financial crises
speculators would have an incentive to
sell currency short in the hopes of
making a profit when the crisis deepened
and when the crisis country's exchange
rate fell as a result they would be like
sharks constantly testing the weakened
weakness of nations but with the IMF
speculators have smaller incentives to
attack a currency because speculators
typically will have smaller resources
for offense then the IMF has to play
defense the speculators realize that
their attacks could turn out to be
highly unprofitable the IMF exists
because and only because of cooperation
among the developed nations of the world
the IMF's resources come mainly from the
money that countries pay as their
capital subscription when they become
members quotas broadly reflect the size
of each member's economy the larger a
country's economy in terms of output and
the larger and more variable its trade
the larger its quota or subscription
tends to be the world's biggest economy
the United States has the largest quota
in the IMF quotas together with the
equal number of basic votes each member
has determine a country's voting power
for IMF decisions quotas also help
determine how much countries can buy
from the IMF today we have thought about
monetary policy coordination but
recognize that coordination does not
occur automatically it's constantly
under threat for example
the 2008 news story recounted that the
coordination of policies between the
European Central Bank and the Fed that
began in 2008 came under threat in 2011
when oil prices began to rise as the
result of political upheaval in Libya
and elsewhere in the Mideast the ECB
worried about the inflationary effects
of the oil price increases and leaned in
the direction of tighter policy the Fed
worried about the recessionary effects
of the oil price increases lean the
other way in the direction of continued
monetary ease keep in mind that the ECB
has a different policy mandate than the
Fed its mandate is to fight inflation
while the feds mandate is to fight
inflation and maintain full employment
as oil prices began to increase and put
upward pressure on prices in Europe and
the United States a real possibility
existed that the ECB would raise
interest rates while the Fed would
continue to keep them low if that
occurred we would predict that the euro
price of the dollar would fall providing
additional stimulus to the US economy at
the cost to the United States of
additional upward pressure on prices
coordination of policy is important but
sometimes that coordination is a fragile
thing thank you the great courses is a
unique publisher for more than 20 years
we produced college-level courses taught
by only the most engaging professors
that universities like Harvard Stanford
Princeton Vanderbilt and Georgetown have
to offer we've created a University of
the best everyone has the capacity to
carry on learning designed in careful
collaboration with our customers our
courses are hand crafted from beginning
to end for the needs of lifelong
learners like you most publishers don't
guarantee their work we do every great
course comes with our lifetime
satisfaction guarantee if a course is
anything short of completely satisfying
you can return it for another course or
for a full refund no questions asked the
only thing left is your decision just
say no to the dead time of car radio
chatter or junk television and embark on
exciting intellectual adventures with
the great courses great learning
experiences that will stay with you for
the rest of your life visit us online at
the great courses com to browse through
our extensive catalog of over 350
comprehensive courses in subjects such
as history science literature better
living
philosophy Fine Arts and more or give us
a call at one eight hundred eight three
two two four one two and speak to our
knowledgeable customer care team the
great courses the leader in lifelong
learning
you